[Musique]
entassés dans leurs tiroirs
interstellaire des shadoks sont sur le
point de mourir de faim l'egypte y sont
toujours à la recherche d'un chapeau
perdu dans le cosmos il faut savoir que
les chapeaux des jib y était un peu
comme des téléphones mais est tellement
perfectionner qu'il n'y avait même pas
besoin de parler de dents il n'y avait
qu'à penser issa émettait quentin jbe
par exemple avec une musique dans la
tête tous les autres jbe pouvait écouter
[Musique]
ou bien les écoutez pas ça dépend des
hommes
un jour c'était le chapeau perdu qui se
remettait à y mettre
il y avait quelque part dans l'espace
quelque chose qui pensait avec le
chapeau jbe sur la tête et qui pensait
plutôt mal c'était un pauvre chat d'oc
affamés qui l'avait télé chez il avait
obtenu dire que les chapeaux bibis
servent et à réfléchir
il se prenait pour un jeune homme
intelligent il dit c'est qu'il pense et
les autres qu'il n'avait jamais vu ça
naturellement le croyait mairie chapou
dgipi marché dans les deux sens et ils
essayèrent d'insuffler aux shadoks une
mauvaise pensée qui n'aurait pas pu
avoir à lui tout seul ça marchait alors
ils décidèrent pour passer le temps de
leur insuffler comme ça des quantités
d'autres mauvaises pensées amusante
[Musique]